معنا من تلبيب مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس كيف تبدو اتجاهات النقاش داخل
اسرائيل ان كان على مستوى
المسؤولين الموجودين في الحكومه وايضا على
المستوى الاخر في الجهات الامنيه
المعنيه نعم سلمى دعيني فقط اشير الان الى
هذا الخبر العاجل الذي ورد للتو عن صافرات
انذار تدوي الان في مدينه ديروت بغلاف غزه
الشمالي يبدو ان ذلك ياتي في اعقاب دفعه
صاروخيه قد اطلقت من داخل قطاع غزه باتجاه
هذه المدينه اذا صافرات الانذار تدوي الان
في مدينه ديروت بغلاف غزه الشمالي فيما
يتعلق بمساله الصفقه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو كان واضحا في المؤتمر الصحفي يوم
امس حين قال بان ايه اسرائيل لن تستسلم
ولن تخضع للشروط التي وضعتها حماس في ردها
على صفقه التبادل او الافكار التي طرحت في
قمه باريس لكن من الواضح ان بنيامين
نتنياهو لم يوصد الباب كليا على استمرار
الحوار والنقاش من اجل التوصل الى صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى حيث لم يقل بصريح العباره
بان اسرائيل ترفض المقترح او الرد رد حركه
حماس على هذه الصفقه من ناحيه اخرى راينا
ايضا موقف وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف
جالانت الذي قال بانه اخبره ايضا لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن الذي زار
اسرائيل وهذا الموقف الذي عبر عنه جلنت
يقول بان حركه حماس صاغت ردها على نحو لا
يمكن لاسرائيل القبول به وان هذا يعني
استمرار الحرب بل ربما توسعها الى مناطق
اخرى من ناحيه ثانيه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو اراد ايضا كما يبدو الضغط على
المقاومه الفلسطينيه من اجل ربما دفعها
الى تليين مواقفها او القول بانها ليست في
موقف او موضع يمكنها ان تقدم شروط في اطار
هذه الصفقه حين قال في المؤتمر الصحفي
ليله امس بان اسرائيل سوف توسع من عمليتها
العسكريه في قطاع غزه وقال في هذا السياق
بانه اوعز الى الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالاستعداد من اجل العمل في مدينه رفح رغم
ان هذه المساله لا تبدو انها تحظى بموافقه
امريكيه وموافقه من جانب الاداره
الامريكيه وهذا ما كان المح اليه حقيقه
رئيس او وزير الخارجيه انتوني بلينكن
بالامس عندما قال بان اسرائيل تعرضت لحدث
غير انساني في السابع من اكتوبر لكن عليها
انلا تتعامل بالمثل مع الفلسطينيين وا
اجاب على سؤال يتعلق في مساله توسيع
العمليه العسكريه في رفع عندما قال بان
على اسرائيل ان تتوقع الحذر فيما اذا
ارادت ان توسع عملياتها هناك لكن هذا
تهديد واضح وصريح من جانب اسرائيل من جانب
وزير الدفاع ومن جانب ايضا رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو
لمقاومه الفلسطينيه في محاوله للضغط عليها
والتاثير عليها لتليين المواقف فيما يتعلق
بصفقه التبادل هذه هذا اليوم سوف ينعقد
مجلس الحرب في اسرائيل من اجل مناقشه
المقترح الذي قدم من جانب حركه حماس ليس
اكيدا اننا سنعرف ماذا ستكون الاجابه
بمعنى هل ستعلن اسرائيل بشكل واضح وصريح
انها ترفض هذا المقترح او على الاقل
تناقشه دون ان تعلن موقفها عليه وهذا يبقي
الباب مفتوحا حقيقه على مزيد من الاخذ
والرد وعلى مزيد من المفاوضات وعلى مزيد
من الحوارات لكن من الواضح بان و الوزير
بيني جانس يقود خطا يختلف شيئا ما عن وزير
الدفاع ورئيس الوزراء في هذا المنحى لانه
هو يضع في راس سلم الاولويات وسلم الاهداف
مساله استعاده الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتج
جزينه داخل قطاع غزه ربما هو لا يقول بانه
يجب انهاء الحرب وانسحاب اسرائيل من داخل
قطاع غزه لكن هو يقول بان الان ربما يجب
ان تكون الاولويه من اجل الافراج عن
الاسرى الاسرائيليين واتمام الصفقه وهنا
ربما يضع جانس خطوطا حمراء امام بنيامين
نتنياهو لانه اذا راى بان بنيامين نتنياهو
يريد ان يعطل هذه الصفقه من اجل قضايا
تتعلق ببقائه في سده الحكم وتتعلق ببقاء
توليف الضيقه وارضاء شركائه في اليمين
المتطرف سموتريش وبينغ فير فهذا ربما يون
يقود يقود بيني جانس ربما الى الانسحاب من
حكومه الطوارئ دعيني فقط بعجاله اشير الى
ان هنالك على الاقل اعتراض صاروخي في سماء
مدينه ديروت في اعقاب صافرات الانذار التي
دوت قبل قليل وقد ابلغنا عنها ويبدو ان
هنالك دفعه صاروخيه كانت تستهدف مدينه
ديروت هذه المدينه تعرضت لكثير من الدفعات
الصاروخيه في عمر هذه الحرب و دوت فيها
صافرات الانذار قبل قليل وعلى الاقل هنالك
اعتراض صاروخان من جانب منظومه القبه
الحديديه في سماء المدينه شكرا جزيلا لك
من تلبيب مراسلنا لياس كرام